hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from round three
of 2021 uh tata still chess tournament
it's fabiana carwana versus young shisht
of duda
and this is uh i'm pretty sure the most
complicated game of round three
i'll let you guys decide but it's uh
it's it's completely crazy so without
further ado
uh let's check it out as fabi has the
white pieces so fabi with the white
pieces
opens with e4 we have e5 by duda knight
to f3 and already very interesting from
the start knight f6
uh duda goes for the petrov defense
which is uh very very
bold as fabi is known to be a a great
expert in the petrov
that's i know it sounds kind of weird to
say something like that because
these guys are experts in every opening
but he did
prepare the patter of defense uh
intensely for the world's championship
match against magnus carlsen so
of course fabi knows his way around this
uh maybe a little bit more than around
other openings so knight captures on e5
going for the main line d6 and now
knight back to f3
we have knight captures on e4 and now
knight to c3 going for the
names of each attack uh we have knight
captures
d captures and now bishop to e7 just
continuing development uh for those of
you who are
maybe uh only beginning your chess
journey here uh you might think
why not pin the bish pin the knight with
bishop to g4
uh this is one of the cases where this
is a bit too early to do something like
this because for example after h3
bishop h5 and queen d5 you get a nice
double attack on the bishop and the pawn
here
and why black will be forced to give up
the bishop and already we're just
starting the game and
already lost the bishop pair and the
white will enjoy a great advantage
as it is an open game two bishops are to
be preferred
so the captures on c3 uh fabi uh
duda continues with bishop to e7
prepares the castle and the bishop to e3
by fabi
knight to d7 and now queen to d2 fabi
prepares the castle queen side of course
he knows black is castling kingside and
he wants to attack on the king side
so castles by both players so castles
castles and now
knight to f6 and here bishop to d3
and here duda goes for c5 and we reach
the position that
is known as the leak variation as during
the
2018 world church championship match
between carlson and caruana
this position has been leaked uh on an
accident by fabi's team uh and then
everyone thought it was like uh some
sort of a
mental warfare to you know try and
confuse magnus and his team to think
that
they were preparing this for for their
next game it was pretty crazy i don't
know if you guys remember that but here
this is the position from that leak
variation and known moves here are rook
h the e1 uh but here fabi goes for a
different move he actually goes to rook
h to g1
and what's the rook doing on g1 well
probably
ready to support this push of a pawn to
g4
uh so duda not eager to find out he
continues uh his attack on the queen
side
b5 and now uh fabi goes for it he pushes
g4
and this is not upon you capture if you
capture the pawn you're
just dead lost for example knight
captures on g4
bishop to h6 and already uh it's
extremely hard for black okay you might
not be dead lost but it uh
it is very unpleasant uh you cannot
capture the bishop
and you have to play something it is
just a very ugly position
but i'm going to show what happens if
the bishop is captured just queen
captures and now
uh uh checkmate is being threatened here
and also here since the bishop covers h7
so g6 is pretty much your only move but
then you just sacrifice everything
bishop captures
f captures who wrote captures with check
h captures queen captures with
check and now after a few more checks
you're gonna bring the other rook into
the attack
and now you can either start giving up
pieces or just allow white to deliver a
nice checkmate
so this is uh these are the kind of
moves that are in the position if you
accept such uh uh such a pawn uh well
gift uh so here the duda goes for bishop
to b7
and now queen to e2 guarding that knight
on f3
uh so queen to e2 and now c4 challenging
this bishop here
and fabi bravely goes bishop to f5
saying i dare you to play g6
even though this was not played but uh
this doesn't really do anything because
after let's say knight d4 you don't
you you can never capture this bishop if
you capture it knight captures an f5 and
it's just a terrible
terrible position for for black to play
all of the lines are open
to reach the white king and it's just
going to be bad after g5
uh the queen is coming to h5 and it's
just going to be all over
so here after bishop to f5 uh rook to e8
by duda
and now knight to d4 by fabi again uh
trying to trying to get duda well not
trying to but
claiming that the g6 is still on not an
option
uh because queen to d2 now for example
and again
uh there's no uh point in capturing the
bishop if you capture
it just opens up this rook's diagonal
king h8 now knight captures on b5 the
bishop is coming to d4
and it's going to be an incredibly
difficult position to defend the defend
even though it might be playable
uh it's not something a human would do
so here
knight to d5 uh uh freeing up that f6
square for the bishop you want to get
your bishop to this diagonal
uh and here fabi thought for some uh
some long time
uh and played knight to e6 and this is a
quite an excellent square for the knight
the knight cannot be captured here at
least for the moment because you don't
even win material because this comes
with
check and you're also going to win the
knight here so
it's if anything it's it's terrible for
black so instead we have
queen to a5 by duda going for that a2
pawn
and now uh here uh fabi needs to decide
what to do and here
fabi played queen to f3 but we are going
to show what happens after the very very
tricky rook captures on d5 as there was
a lot of discussion on rook captures on
d5
uh here you accept with bishop captures
on d5 and now
knight captures on g7 and this is a
really crazy line because if the knight
is accepted
then g5 again you open up uh
the h file for the queen and there's not
much for black to do here queen captures
an a2 you're gonna go queen to h5
and now there is no no no good
continuation if rookie trade
blocking the this h7 pawn just queen h6
check king to g8
and now bishop the d for threatening
checkmate
and once you play something like bishop
to f8 the defending against this just
queen f6 and there is no defense against
queen captures on h8 checkmate
you can deliver one little check here
but after king to d2
it's just all over so this is uh what
happens
but it's not forced like i said after
knight captures on g7 of course uh
uh dude would not capture the knight he
would play queen captures on a2
and now the position is roughly equal
you could
try try a lot of things here but it
doesn't look all that all that
great for uh for white so instead
of this very tricky line after queen to
a5 fab it doesn't go for this knight
grab but rather queen to f3 and it looks
pretty crazy
uh because you put your queen in the
line of fire here the bishop
is uh uh well indirectly attacking the
queen x-raying it so to say
but there is no knight captures on c3
with check the king is still on c1 so
this is a
one of the one of the rare cases where
it's good not to play the prophylactic
king to b1
uh and here we have bishop to f6 uh not
going for knight captures on c3 right
away even though you can do that also
uh could be could be very nice we're
going to show at knight captures on c3
now does come with an attack on the
queen
and after queen captures on b7 knight
captures an a2 with
check and after king to b1 you can do a
lot of things but there doesn't seem to
be a way to finish this for black so
it's a it's a really crazy position for
example f captures on h6
uh f captures on e6 can be played uh but
uh you know not not a a lot can happen
here
bishop captures on h7 also move king
captures
queen back to e4 with check and now uh
well uh anything could happen here but
uh this is a this is a really crazy line
you don't capture the bishop here you go
king to h8 and now it's it's a question
what do you what do you do here uh so
what uh what could be done here
after for example this knight check king
to b1
uh it doesn't seem uh like uh like black
has
all that many choices so uh instead
after this queen to have to remove uh
duda did not go for the
capture right away he played bishop to
f6 first uh
and now comes g5 by fabi and this is a
very sneaky position
uh attacking that bishop here if you
move the bishop it's just a
game over captures captures and queen
captures an f7 check
followed by rook g3 to h3 will end in
checkmate
uh so here after this g5 move we have
bishop captures on c3 now do the ghost
for it by capturing with the bishop
and now uh it's a good is a good moment
for you to pause the video and try to
find the only move that gives advantage
to fabi
while i give you a couple of seconds
oh uh sorry about that i heard meadow he
was uh messing around with with the
trash can
meadow is a naughty dog uh so uh for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as this is the only good
move for white here in this position and
that is bishop captures on h7
with check so what do you do here of
course this square is covered by the
by the knight so you have to either
capture or go to h8 king h8 doesn't work
because queen h5 and then it's just lost
so you have to capture it king captures
an h7 and now
g6 with check another great continuation
by fabi
opening up lines in to the black king
but also messing up black's pawn
structure here
so f captures on g6 and now comes
knight to g5 with check and here king
the h8 and
now another excellent pause the video
moment so
uh once again feel free to pause the
video and find the
again the the only move that allows
whites to play for the win while i give
you a couple of seconds this is not an
easy one
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting
not rook captures on d5 even though this
is also a great move but
bishop to d4 bishop to d4 is a is a
crazy
crazy crazy line but we're going to show
rook captures on d5 just
because i know a lot of you decided to
play this point is that after bishop
captures and queen captures of course we
have to play this queen captures
on a uh on a2 now with the bishop
covering the square uh queen a1 will be
checkmate
so here we don't really have a good
continuation we would have to sell for a
perpetual
either by going knight knight check
followed by an ig5 check knight f7 check
knight g5 check
or we could capture this bishop here but
it doesn't help all that much queen a1
chair king d2 and now we lose the rook
here on g1
and again uh we don't we simply don't
have ways of
finishing the attack we would again have
to settle for a draw a knight f7 check
knight g5 check knight f7 check
so this is what happens after rook
captures on d5 very very uh
you know uh exciting move but it doesn't
really work
bishop to d4 on the other hand is just
it's just a killer move because here
uh now you have to really really figure
out what you're doing now
you could run into queen h3 check when
h7 check queen captures on g7 the bishop
here is a monster
so black must eliminate it so bishop
captures on d4 was played
rook captures on d4 and now again what
do you play here
here knight to f6 duda has to give up
the bishop because with
the rook here you simply cannot allow
any
any
checks now for example if you go after a
queen captures an a2
just rook to h4 with check king g8 and
now queen to f7 is checkmate so this is
out of the question
so after rook captures on b4 we have
knight to f6
now if rook comes here you can simply
block that with knight to h4
but the bishop is now free for grabs and
this is exactly what fabi does queen
captures on b7
rook 8 to b8 and the knock comes queen
to f7
again putting pressure on the pawn here
uh then again we have some very sneaky
ideas if you allow this capture then for
example
checks knight has to move and then you
can deliver checkmate with the queen
so here instead we have rook to e1 with
check and now of course not
capturing but rather rook back to d1
rook captures on g1 with
check rook captures and rook to e8
now do that with the deadly threat of
rook to e1 if you're not careful if you
play something like this now then
you are getting checkmated captures
captures and queen to e1 checkmate
so after rook the e8 we have knights the
e6 blocking
while threatening checkmate and now uh
there is only one move that saves duda
and he goes for it rook captures on e6
queen captures and queen captures on a2
and now we reach this position where
uh duda is up two points but fabi is up
the exchange and here
uh kind of a first critical movement of
the game where fabi needs to decide how
to continue this
this brilliancy and i'm just going to
show it because it's
uh this game is too complicated like
every move we could explain
for ages as the game is too complicated
so here fabi played queen to h3
check but rook captures on g6 seems to
be the way to go it doesn't
look like there's a clear continuation
but you have to dodge a lot of checks
queen a1
check king d2 now d5 uh trying to
advance those pawns
and now after queen to f7 threatening
checkmate now you go for knight
to e4 with check king e3 and now
queen captures on b2 guards against
checkmate queen to f8
checking to h7 now queen to f5
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries
but now queen c3 checked king f4 and now
queen to d2 with check king e5 and now
queen captures on f2
not allowing any nasty discoveries
because queen captures queen
so here white would have to trade
captures captures and then for example
rook to g1 and now white would have a
beautiful beautiful position that
is winning for white because the white
king is super active the black king is
cut off from the game completely
and you're just gonna pick off all of
these pawns and win the game
but it's not uh of course not an easy
sequence to spot i just show it for
for you guys to enjoy so here fabi went
for a queen to h3 check
uh came to g8 now queen to e6 with check
king to h7 and here fabi went for sort
of a repetition
check king g8 and now not queen to e6
but rather
queen to a3 he of course cannot allow
check followed by queen captures rook so
here
fabi decided to go for this end game
where uh of course dude accepts gladly
captures captures and now six pawns
against four
rook against the knight can can fabi win
this so duda starts by activating the
king king f7
king to d2 with a6 and now king to e3 so
now
we have this endgame on 36 opposed to
this one that we just mentioned
like this one where the white king was
super active and the black king was
stuck here in the corner but
you cannot calculate all of this and
fabi was extremely low on time
even though he was uh only only uh move
29 when it was time to make such a
decision and you need to reach move 40
to gain additional time
so king e3 knight to d5 check king to d4
uh and now knight back to e7 and here
again you have to decide what to do here
but it's uh
it's such a crazy position that it's
hard to even
uh think uh think like that he uh
although not really here fabi played
rook to e1
when in fact lekko peter lecko in the
live stream said that a4 here was a
critical move
and it is in fact true a4 is a critical
move because you're trying to weaken the
c4 square of course black will not
capture
but after something like king a6 you can
trade here and now
after rook g5 for example attacking this
pawn
knight f5 check blocking the rook king
to c3
and now you are reaching this pawn for
example king f6
pushes back the rook and now g5 now you
will finally
reach reach this pawn if knight before
defending you can play rook to d1
going for trying to get black to capture
here so you can capture here
and here so here uh black would defend
king e5 and now c3
knight to f3 and only now do you go h3
defending your pawn and now after any
movie is played for example
king to e6 you're going to capture on b5
so this is how you win the pawn
but again this is uh incredibly
complicated stuff but
interestingly peter leko spotted a4
immediately
so he has a a very brilliant positional
mind so here
rook the e1 by fabi king to e8 and this
is a crucial tempo for duda he needs to
get his king
one step closer to defending those pawns
and now a4
but now a4 is not as potent as the king
can defend that pawn
so came to d7 we have captures captures
and now
uh here with this captures and captures
both players to reach time control
and have reached additional time so here
rook to g1
paralyzing the knight as the pawns would
fall here king to c6
and now h4 kind of baiting the knights
to go after this pawn so the the rook
can go after these pawns
so here knight f5 check king c3 and duda
grabs the pawn with
king to b4 uh and now knight to f3
attacking the rook we have rook captures
on g6 and now
knight to d4 threatening to pick up this
pawn with check
c3 phobia kicks away and here duda did
uh spend some time thinking about
whether to go for this
check uh for example check king to a5
and now for example after knight a1 rook
captures on g7
but you will not you will not be able to
do anything here uh black can always
bring the knight here with check you you
can bring the king here push the pawns
and it's gonna be a two-sided two-sided
game as black will also start pushing
the pawns if black exchanges this pawn
he will get two connected past pawns
it's going to be very dangerous
so here instead after c3 uh duda decided
not to go for that uh as
you know he he fought a lot not to lose
this game he played knights to e2
instead
and now rook captures on g7 knights the
f4 now threatening this check which
would kick away the king from the
defense of the pawn and then
pick up the c3 pawn king to a5 by fabi
and now knight back to e2 by duda going
after this pawn once again
king before knight to f4 king to a5 and
here
knight back to e2 and here fabi played
king to b4
and it was in this position that the
players agreed to a draw
because neither side can make progress
and indeed the engine the almighty
engine
agrees with them as uh the engine
evaluates this as a 0.00 position
uh so definitely definitely an
unfinished masterpiece by fabi but
it's often the case with fabi's games
these games are just too too complicated
i don't know i guess he just knows so
many computer lines that uh he he goes
into
these deep engine positions and then you
know no one can make sense of such
positions
he does he does an amazing job at it but
then when it's time for that little
little tweak uh
then of course it's too too difficult
for a human but it's also very
interesting how leko spotted that a4
move
and uh but but then then again lego
maybe wouldn't get such positions so you
know to each his own
uh but yeah uh the game ended a draw
here and uh
a brilliant what what what an unfinished
masterpiece this was
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it it may be a bit too
complicated it took a while for me to
record this but
we have to cover you know such such
games with such brutal brutal positions
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we'll show more games from
round three and only then will i show
the standings as i said we're going to
show the standings
after round three uh i would like to
thank chief arbiter lotter schmidt
uh brian flynn frank banner gerhardt
homer and thomas bardo
bardoskas for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata still 2021
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day